Jeremy is in Indiana hi Jeremy welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi there Dave
thanks Jamaat all sure how can I help
well my new wife and I have a bit of a
bit of an issue we are in the middle of
a custody battle and I am a pilot I have
a the option to upgrade with my company
and we're trying to stay in this
location and if I hurry up I can get the
hours I need to upgrade and stay in this
location right now but that would
require us taking about four thousand
dollars out of our seeking fund that you
have for lawyers and spending that and
renting an airplane and getting the time
that we need and really we both lose
kind of thought that we should call you
so how much is in your lawyer sinking
fund and boy is that not a true
statement right there that's not a good
feeling
we have a right around $10,000 total but
that includes the emergency fund we're
on baby step two we're actually going to
financial piece tomorrow and everyone
could be dealt I talked to you today but
uh yeah so about nine thousand in in
cash and what's your household income
our household income right now is
sixty-five and if I do this our
household income my salary will double
so it'll go up to about 115 to 120 in
what period of time do this uh six weeks
Wow
that's why it's a pressing issue we just
kind of it all got sprung on us Saturday
morning and you kind of do you what is
your cars worth I'll call both of our
cars are paid off and what are they
worth
oh I Drive a 2000 Honda Civic Dave card
it's I don't know 1500 bucks and her her
she got an Impala probably three
thousand do you own anything that you
can show nothing week nothing we could
sell nothing that gets all right now to
come up with the money and I guess the
issue for us is that we have the money
and it just should you spend it is the
question yeah the the court there's no
doubt that this is a good expenditure no
doubt but you know I don't want to make
a choice between furthering your career
and your and lose a custody battle yeah
that's the choice that's on my plate if
I understood your question right whether
or not you spend this versus a potential
emergency that's vague out there yeah
you go do this and you double your
income in six weeks no doubt no question
drop the drop a dime on that baby but I
don't want you to turn around then and
have zero money because the lawyer needs
some money or you never get to see your
kid again right so I don't know what
your projections are on that or how
where this custody battle is how heated
it is what the timeline on it is what
the legal fee need is but you got to
assess all of that against Lester Yeah
right now that's all paid up she's still
working off a retainer and you know
we've got old everything we've ever so
probably in six weeks you're not gonna
need more money that's correct but you
might in five months or ten months we
absolutely will yeah three or six months
yes okay yeah I think you do it you go
forward because we're not putting your
custody battle and in jeopardy is what
we're saying
and you know you're just starting with
less of an emergency fund to start your
baby step to that you're gonna throw at
the debt but you're gonna double your
freaking income in six weeks yeah
definitely
I spend four grand to do that every time
I got it yep good question thank you for
joining us this is the Dave Ramsey show